what do you guys think that men want  I kind of agree with us like it's kind  of weird  um some guys might just actually just  want looks or body  um some guys want to see like where the  girls going in the career or what she's  actually interested in some guys I don't  know  um  okay they might have some similarities  or something I did I don't know I don't  actually know what about you  um  from what I've gathered from from guys  that have been interested in me  um as well as like guy friends  um most of the time they don't want a  plus-sized girl because either they're  afraid or embarrassed or perfect  whatever  um or if they do they only want to be  low-key about it they don't want to show  you off they don't want people to know  that they're that they're like talking  to you or or trying to do a thing with  you